BUKOLA AYODELE: Charlie
has a new role, Platform
Administrator, and he
is tasked with ensuring
all the infrastructure created
by all of his company's teams
are in compliance with
governance requirements.
Let's see how Config Sync
makes his life easier.
Charlie's team are using
Kubernetes for development.
One of the many
benefits of Kubernetes
is its declarative workflow.
You can specify how many
instances of an application
you want running, and be
sure that Kubernete, will
ensure that state for you.
But sometimes, the state
of running clusters
itself can become out
of sync with what's
on paper when un-vetted changes
are applied to a live cluster.
It can be difficult to
know what's actually
going on in your cluster.
When this happens,
getting your cluster back
into a last known good state
when something goes wrong
becomes problematic.
That's why Charlie proposes
using Config Sync for git ops
workflow.
Config Sync allows
cluster operators
to manage Kubernete
clusters using
files called configs
stored in git repositories.
Config Sync watches,
for updates to those
files and applies changes
to all relevant clusters
automatically.
By locking down direct
access to Kubernete API,
he can require that all cluster
configuration changes are
propagated using Config Sync.
This way all
changes are reviewed
before they are submitted.
Declarative tooling
like Config Sync
means that git will
become the source of truth
and accurately reflect what's
happening in your live cluster.
For a platform administrator
like Charlie, this is a win.
And as the entire
system becomes easier
to manage, debug, and monitor.
Let's see an example of
how Config Sync can be used
to keep a repository in sync.
In this example, we've
created a cluster,
made ourselves a cluster
admin, and installed
the normal command and
the Config Sync operator
on to the cluster we operate on.
The first step is
to configure the git
repo storing the Configs our
cluster will be synced from.
We'll create a configuration
file called Config Management
YAML that will be applied
to all of our clusters.
This file tells Kubernetes
which clusters to operate on.
And it provides information
about the git repository,
including which branch
and folder to sync from.
We can set up
credentials for accessing
private repos here as needed.
Once that's applied, you can
see that Config Sync operator
actually creates pods in the
Config Management namespace.
These are services
that run to make
sure the cluster's
desired state matches up
with its actual state.
For example, this repo
contains instructions
for creating namespace for
testing and development,
among other things.
But what if we were to delete
one of these namespaces
manually?
This would be an example of an
actual and desired state being
out of sync.
Luckily Config Sync captures
that within a few seconds,
and spins up a new version
of the deleted namespace,
keeping everything
running as it should.
With Config Sync, you can
pair git ops approach with git
for storage and versioning.
And your changes will
be automatically synced
to the cluster to ensure a
consistent review process.
With this approach, all
configuration changes
follow the consistent
review process
that are validated and
approved before being applied,
just like code would be.
This makes it much
easier for Charlie
to ensure all teams follow
this process consistently
so it can scale
across the company.
So that's Config Sync.
Make sure to check out
the description for links,
to more resources on it.
And like and subscribe
to this channel
for more videos
about Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]